face à l'urgence climatique le transport
aérien n'a pas d'autre choix que de se
verdir Jérôme Bouchard bonjour bonjour
associer chez Oliver Wyman et expert en
aéronautique alors on va le voir à tous
les acteurs du secteur sont sur le pont
le secteur qui dispose en fait de toute
une palette de briques de briques
technologique qu'il faut assembler un
petit peu comme dans un puzzle on va les
passer en revue ensemble sachant que
elles ont toutes une temporalité un
petit peu différente certaines briques
existent déjà et d'autres seront
effectives dans un horizon un peu plus
lointain déjà le renouvellement des
flottes d'avion c'est vraiment un levier
de décarbonation sur lequel on peut agir
maintenant tout de suite c'est quelque
chose qui nous est disponible maintenant
en quelques données les avions en 20 ans
ont amélioré leur performance en termes
d'émission de 20%. et ce chiffre est
tout à fait extensible des avions il y a
50 ans et mettez à peu près 50% de
carbone mais c'est suffisant pour que le
secteur soit neutre en émission carbone
la raison 2050 de miséricorde là dessus
bien sûr bien sûr
c'est une petite partie d'équation qui
je le rappelle est immédiatement
accessible donc aujourd'hui un avion a
une durée de vie d'à peu près 25 ans
donc les avions qui sont mis en service
en 2020 finiront leur vie en 2047 donc
on va se dire que l'aviation est un
secteur à cycle long donc les progrès
qui sont faits sont faits mais par
contre la flotte ne va pas se verdir
immédiatement elle continuera à
progresser lentement mais la croissance
du trafic passager fera que
malheureusement on restera toujours dans
un surplus d'émission alors il y a un
autre levier effectivement tout de suite
à la marge ou pas je vous pose la
question mais on peut jouer sur la
trajectoire je savais pas la trajectoire
de vol de manière optimisée en gros
l'avion l'idée c'est qu'il soit ultra
connecté
qui communique entre les avions et donc
et leur environnement et donc ils
consomment un carburant c'est ça l'idée
c'est exactement ça alors ça pour la
peine c'est un vrai levier
supplémentaire ça peut apporter 3 à 4%
de réduction de l'émission par vol alors
on n'est pas encore au verdissement
total mais c'est un vrai premier pas le
fait d'optimiser les trajectoires et
particulièrement indécente vers les
aéroports en utilisant la gravité va
permettre de réduire la consommation et
donc les émissions bon il faut après des
carburants aussi qui soit moins
polluants et c'est là que les
biocarburant vont entrer en jeu c'est la
solution qui apparaît aujourd'hui comme
la plus pragmatique la plus simple à
court terme d'ailleurs les compagnies
commencent à les utiliser mais encore
une fois la marche très progressivement
aujourd'hui on a 1% 2% de leur réservoir
qui remplit sur ce qu'on appelle le
systèmeable la vieille chaîne fioul il y
a beaucoup de biocarburant c'est vrai
mais je pense que ça ne sera pas la
meilleure solution parce que les
biocarburants ça demande des terres
arables ça demande aussi pas mal d'eau
donc ça déplace un peu le problème donc
c'est pas une solution les deux
carburants c'est une première solution
mais moi je crois plutôt à une sorte de
circularité c'est à dire que on a des
projets aujourd'hui dans l'industrie
aéronautique où on va récupérer le
carbone de l'air dans des grosses
machines qui ressemblent à des séchoirs
à cheveux géants et où ce carbone après
on va le recombiner pour en faire du
carburant qui sera réinjecté dans les
avions donc ça c'est pour moi cette
circularité carbone elle est beaucoup
plus intéressante elle est un peu plus
loin technologiquement parlant mais à
horizon 2030 par exemple mais elle a au
moins le mérite de ne pas rajouter
d'empreinte carbone à ce qui est déjà
j'allais dire consommer en même temps la
France a des engagements qui sont forts
sur ces biocarburants on va pouvoir
remplir ces objectifs là
la vraie question aujourd'hui à court
terme c'est les subventions qui sont
liées au biocarburant on a bien vu
qu'aux États-Unis récemment le fait de
donner un dollar par galon a fait
développer considérablement l'histoire
des biocarburants maintenant est-ce que
on arrivera à faire la même chose en
France je le souhaite et je l'espère
est-ce que ça sera vraiment durable
c'est une autre question en même temps
dans les deux cas ça coûte cher
bioparbure en carburant de santé c'est
très cher et là on se dit que les prix
des billets d'avion vont devoir
forcément augmenter signe c'est une
quasi certitude ça alors déjà ça coûte
plus cher oui on va dire que du
carburant de synthèse ou du biocarburant
c'est 4 fois plus cher que le kérosène
et on sait que le prix d'un billet
d'avion dans un billet d'avion c'est
30%. donc déjà si on ne fait juste un
petit calcul mathématiques ça tient pas
boum ça tient pas mais ça tient pas du
tout donc c'est pour ça que je vous
disais il faut peut-être penser à des
subventions il y a d'autres aides
premier point deuxième point est-ce
qu'on va avoir une augmentation du coût
des billets d'avion bon moi j'ai pas de
boule de cristal mais on sent bien que
c'est une tendance de fond
lié au carburant ou lié à une éventuelle
taxe carbone qui pourrait être mise en
place à terme il va falloir que le
passager dans une certaine mesure
contribue à la réduction des émissions
maintenant j'espère parce que je suis
passager moi aussi qu'on va réussir à
maintenir cette augmentation dans une
mesure acceptable bon après on peut
rêver voler dans des agents des
batteries ou des piles à combustible le
problème c'est qu'elles sont lourdes ces
batteries et pas assez puissantes donc
la solution ce sont peut-être des
moteurs hybrides à la fois électrique et
thermique oui moi je crois quand même à
une horizon 10 à 15 ans à l'hybridation
donc on sera pas forcément sur des
avions de type 3 vins voilà qu'on
utilise pour faire Paris Toulouse et
encore moins sur des avions qui nous
permettent de traverser les océans mais
quand on regarde des avions régionaux
pour des trajets de 3-400 km on pourra
avoir des avions hybrides qui
contiennent moins de passagers peut-être
19 passagers comme l'avion Héra Dora
Hero qui a un exemple et qui nous
permettront de voyager là pour la peine
avec d'une émission considérablement
réduite par rapport aux technologies
actuelles donc l'hybridation plus que
tout électrique dans un premier temps
oui l'hybridation plus que le tout
électrique c'est sûr il faudra passer
par cette brique là on y reste après
évidemment ce qui nous fait rêver
d'hydrogène les avions plus gros de plus
longue distance et le pari de
l'hydrogène mais il y a beaucoup
d'obstacles certains disent qu'on n'y
arrivera pas alors moi je suis pas de
cet avis moi je suis un éternel
optimiste l'aviation a toujours vécu de
ces challenge c'est un métier de
pionnier donc il y a 100 ans on pensait
pas qu'on traverserait les océans avec
des 380 qui pèsent 500 tonnes en amenant
500 passagers en moins de 7 heures donc
moi je suis sûr que l'aviation va se
réinventer elle va se décarboner
l'hydrogène est un bon levier pour aller
dans cette direction maintenant c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué parce qu'il
faut réinventer l'avion les avions
n'auront pas la même forme les
réservoirs prendront plus de place
l'hydrogène a une densité énergétique 4
fois moindre calcaire ça va changer
beaucoup de choses dans la façon dont
les avions sont construits Airbus
là-dessus j'imagine du travail sur toute
solution elle travaille sur toutes ces
solutions ils ont des équipes dédiées à
la partie hydrogène long terme mais ils
ont bien compris la temporalité des
briques donc ils ont des petites équipes
sur chacun des sujets allez merci Jérôme
Bouchard merci à vous associez donc chez
Oliver whyman expert en aéronautique
merci
[Musique]